your sister said tonight that she hasn't
seen you this happy in so long and
that's pretty cool for someone who knows
you so well to say what did it feel like
to hear her tell you that
i feel like
it kind of makes me emotional in a weird
way just because
i'm not right
you can't cry
um
yeah no i just think that
i
feel
i think it's like a sense of like i've
walked outside in the world the last few
years and i have a lot of like
overwhelming amount of like guilt and
shame
so for
i'm gonna cry what the hell is wrong
with me but for the first time in like a
really long time i just feel
can you stop
just just you're fine
um sorry i don't know what's going on
collect yourself and no no you deserve
to be collected because we're all like
you are captivating to watch and you're
crushing it out there and if you have
felt that way in the past i love seeing
how you potentially are going to be
feeling moving forward in the future
it's very cool thank you sorry i don't
know why i just cried guys i'm fine
no but honestly it's like yeah i think
like what i was trying to get out was
that i have like the last few years just
been like feeling a little bit shameful
and so it's really nice to have a new
sense of confidence which obviously
comes a lot from val and
being in this show i'm just really
grateful remember
[Music]
crushing it every week
are we loving this experience i'm you
two we were we were i'm no joke we were
i'm texting with like other people
watching the producers and we're just
like we love watching olivia you are
doing so great how is this feeling for
you at this point it feels
i think the best way i can describe it
is it's very rewarding especially this
week learning two dances in such a short
amount of time you have so much pressure
and you're so nervous and especially not
being a dancer a performer
it can be scary and then especially this
week i feel like i was kind of
there were obviously moments where both
dances were very challenging yeah last
year
eval as a vet and the dancer here can
you help me understand the judges a
little bit like carriana's saying you
were safe but len's saying it's so great
and i usually think of len is the harder
one to please like what's going on in
their minds
you know to be honest the judges have
been a really
you know really cool element for us this
season we draw a lot of inspiration from
their feedback also you know as as
lessons like we listen to them so to
some degree like i agree with carrie ann
i i see where she's coming from it
didn't have
the same kick and punch that we had in
the tango or even in the samba yesterday
i hear that
because that's what people love to see
from us but
it did have it wasn't that type of
number it yeah
it had a joyful more you know
artistically like it was more musical
theater
yeah like a power move right and so i
see where she's coming from but i also
then see where len is coming from where
he enjoyed that element so and olivia i
remember you had told me that you were
worried about your acting i saw some
acting tonight you were putting on some
theater
yeah i have no idea where that came from
nervous butch for sure i'll brag for
like you know she's a modest person she
can act she's a star she has presence
that's that's just the truth that's why
her dancing is good she's talented but
she also has presents
so you could definitely act for sure
[Music]
olivia he just said you're a star and
you have star presence is more acting in
your future if you if you feel better
about it
i don't know i mean
i don't know yeah no i don't think i'm
there yet okay honestly i
i don't i honestly don't really know i
think that my sister is gonna one-up me
in that department because she's such a
good actress and i think she's really
taking in our mom's footsteps that i'm
just gonna leave that one to them in
order to keep like reality dance shows
i'll do a different direction